we're at the Oscars now I'm not just
here tonight as a model but as a mother
not bad for a year right it's been two
[Music]
[Applause]
remember what happens at the Oscars
stays at the Oscars okay
[Applause]
found to happen there are a lot of
directors here tonight we just wanted
them to know we do more than comedy oh
that was my life well I guess it's mine
now son how would you know you were
always gone when I was a kid see acting
oh my God
I just soiled myself the academy said I
didn't have enough money for an opening
number I'm gonna do one anyway
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
before we move on I want to make a quick
program note about acceptance speeches
as always the producers are incredibly
concerned with them running along it's
not that we don't have time for long
speeches it's that we don't have time
for boring speeches I just want to thank
everybody I've ever met in my entire
life
more did I really earn this or did I
just wear you all down well I'll just
say what's in my heart but bump the bomb
right okay
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you I I will drink until next
morning thank you what let me ask her is
not the most important thing in the
world
it's an honor just to be no oh God
to the Oscars because I quit
seemed like a better idea in rehearsal
[Music]
stunts oh my God he tripped me everyone
look under your seat
[Applause]
[Music]
what you're thinking just as you really
start to get into it it's over thanks
for watching for the end and apologies
to Matt Damon we ran out of time for him
good night everybody
[Music]